president Chopp is ordering the Pentagon
to create a separate military branch to
handle space the president announced his
proposed space force yesterday it would
be the first new branch of the Armed
Services since the Air Force was created
in 1947 supporters of the president's
plan say the Air Force doesn't give
space the attention or money it needs
David Martin looks at what it would mean
to have a space force the Air Force
plans to conduct 50 space launches this
year and already operates 77 satellites
on orbit including these GPS satellites
which guide everything from high-tech
weapons to everyday drivers nearly
40,000 Air Force men and women are
currently assigned to space but
president Trump has told the Pentagon to
set up a new branch of the Armed
Services just for space we are going to
have the Air Force and we are going to
have the space force the American Way of
war depends on space which is why
potential adversaries like Russia and
China have developed anti-satellite
weapons a threat brought home in 2007
when China created this vast debris
field by shooting down one of its own
weather satellites General John
heightened the overall commander of US
space forces spoke with 60 minutes in
2015 it was a significant wake-up call
to our entire military until that
singular event I don't think the broader
military realized that that is something
we're gonna have to worry about Doug
lavarro is the former head of space
policy for the Pentagon it's not that
the Air Force has done a bad job but to
bring it further to bring it to where we
need to get to we really need a service
focused on it less than a year ago
defense secretary mattis wrote this
letter saying I do not wish to add a
separate service for space but now his
commander in chief has spoken although
Congress will have the final say for CBS
this morning David Martin at the
Pentagon and we'll see whether Congress
actually moves forward on this same
ambitious plan at this present moment